so a lot of fun moments in the film one
of which a woman says something to the
effect that le minh play a lot of games
true I'll agree with that but also
Elliot women play their own share of
games i'm not going to actually tell you
what those are but always filling in
well then here we go this is where this
is worse can get really fun chat so as J
cuz J plays a guy that has a little bit
of a Casanova thing going on but in a
fun way if you were to coach a group of
la ladies before they were going out huh
in the spirit of j what would you say to
one you're giving him like a super bowl
on the spirit of j in the spirit of day
yes EJ would give them false information
and then he would probably bet each one
of them down that's Jay for you ok but
actually I don't know j-just lives
that's not true I don't think Jalen's I
think JJ's is very honest about what he
wants and who he is so that I give him
credit for that if you're gonna sit down
about you one before the off the neck
down I'd say hand over drink always no
roofies it's just how I checked yourself
from everything and just be careful you
know just um I always say just yeah no
regrets you know if you if you're out to
have a fun time Greg go just no regrets
there's no advice you can give I mean
everyone's so different well there's
also the you know men really all we want
is honesty you know just tell us what
you want you know don't be bashful I
think the things are changing though I
think people are becoming more blunt I
think that we're we're through an age
right now where people are just saying
look I'm not looking for anything ok we
can a B and C and I think that that's
where things are going I have a lot of
friends to date a lot and that's the
world that they live in and um you know
makes it easier on them sure so just
like we're sort of communicating in 140
characters you want the same thing in
our relationships we're just looking for
something that's we're to the point
about it I mean it's that sort of
Witcher they're saying it's not like why
have a pretense about it yeah I believe
so I'm
you know dating love all those things
are hard sure you know you have to make
a lot of compromises in this world
especially in Los Angeles if you've
moved here for a career based life and
that's really what you came here I'm
guessing a you a lot of drive behind you
so you have drive to have the career
that you want in the dream and so now
when you throw a love into the mix and
you find a companion you have to make
compromise as well as they do to make
sure that both can coexist yes they both
take a lot of work in order to do a or b
and so I think that that's where a lot
of the that the problems may arise is
you know one gets more love than the
other the career or the relationship and
it kind of falls to pieces yeah you can
only serve one master sort of thing and
also it helps to just smile and say yes
dear and sometimes keep the mouth shut
well you brought you brought it up
technology I think also does complicate
things quite a bit it's like think about
how many times you miss read an email or
a text or I can't tell you how many
issues I have as a result of that so
like how do people ever really get
together when you say meet me at 3am I
don't tell my wife yeah it's not a
mystery automation and is is you know
you go from the nickel fellowship to
then writing some very fascinating
scenes so you had some activity in the
film so what would you give what advice
would you tell a first or second time
director about orchestrating a sex scene
and you're not in the valley you're
you're doing rehearsals or maybe you're
not privacy is everything you have to
look out for your actors first and
foremost and make sure that the
situation is comfortable and there
aren't you know people leering you know
from behind camera or whatnot you have
to really really just be very it's all
about the actors and you know and also
there's nothing I don't think there
could be anything less sexy than
shooting a sex scene so mechanical and
you know so it's there's there's no
glory and making shooting one of those
things I don't think really but that for
this movie it was very important to
to get that on on film and lastly the
city of La is its own character in the
film which I love can you tell me about
your early memories of La I think Chad
for you i read that it was a little bit
lonely in the beginning you had a TV
that had a couple channels and no
furniture and I can attest to that I
remember those days can you just tell us
an interesting story both of you from
early days in LA studio apartment I had
studio I had really nothing to my name I
never garbage can and I remember that my
buddy and I I mean we hung out all the
time we just said Starbucks I'm into a
Boulevard just talked about acting in
life and love movies and things like
that till all hours in the morning then
we'd come back to my place and we had
nothing to do so we just play um video
games little bubble bobble little super
techno ball holding 50 games cuz that's
all I had was a Nintendo I brought it
with me from from from Buffalo and I
didn't have a table and we're having a
couple beers underage I'm might add and
um we didn't have anything but my VCR
broke so I ripped the top off of it and
found that there was two perfectly sized
beer holders they were just jam right in
the electronics and boom I had a beer
holder it's fantastic that was my coffee
table that's also should a pattern i
should have i buy one of those right all
right that'll be insane literally just
it's beer holder for me I had a I moved
to LA I had a this really really dumpy
apartment that where I could see just
from like one corner right where I sort
of set up my my computer I can see the
Hollywood sign but the problem was we're
sort of near the La Brea Tar Pits and
the entire apartment building smelled
like sulfur and I became immune to but
every time I would you know bring a
friend over my by at that time
girlfriend now wife she would be like
not staying here so I tried so that was
kind of you know I had a pretty
miserable apartment cuz it stank like
eggs yeah is that where the mud
reference Cayman know the mud reference
came out of this you know crazy mind of
mine yeah
and it's all because of the soil because
of the sulfur what it did to my 88 away
in my mind yeah